this episode of GameSpot's Holiday Gift
Guide is presented by Best Buy hello and
welcome to GameSpot's Holiday Gift Guide
2014 i'm jeff kannada last time we ran
down our picks for the top 5 games to
play with friends today i'll give you 5
fantastic new games to play solo there
have been a ton of great games released
in 2014 but these 5 represents some of
my very favorite experiences of the year
if you've got gamers on your list who
love engaging single-player campaigns
finding any of these under their tree
will certainly make them happy
one of the most surprising games of the
year was monoliths phenomenal
middle-earth shadow of Mordor set in the
Lord of the Rings universe players are
able to hack and slash their way through
hordes of orcs and trolls while leveling
up their skills and exploring a vast
open world it's a perfect game for a
solo gamer because every decision you
make and every action you take has an
effect on the game world
this year's Wolfenstein new order proved
the franchise still has legs and guns
lots of guns set in an alternate history
where the Nazis won World War two the
Wolfenstein universe is a hybrid of
sci-fi future tech and greatest
generation era machinery this is a solid
shooter and an exceptionally well
crafted game if you're talking solo
gaming there was no game released this
year that makes you feel more solo than
alien isolation this is a slow
terrifying survival horror game all
about feeling alone and hunted the
fantastic mood lighting and
claustrophobic environments on the PC
Xbox and Playstation make exploration a
harrowing experience a story about my
uncle is only available on PC but it is
well worth seeking out you play as a
young boy who stumbles upon a special
jumpsuit in his uncle's attic that
transports him to a magical world of
floating rocks and glowing
elements there's no killing or violence
of any kind in this one just clever
puzzles vibrant environments and the
Magnificent thrill of speed and agility
divinity original sin is a throwback to
the role-playing games that I grew up on
it asks you to think and investigate and
pay attention
it has devious puzzles and wonderful
quests and really interesting decisions
and the turn-based combat system is as
close to perfect as I've seen in a long
time this is PC role-playing at its best
and while it can be played in co-op I
found the solo experience could be
second to none
so there you go 5 excellent games sure
to keep gamers engrossed and thrall dand
entertained throughout this holiday
season thanks for watching GameSpot's
Holiday Gift Guide 2014 i'm jeff kannada
and have a very happy holiday
you